CINEMATOGRAPHY IS ONE OF
THOSE JOBS THAT YOU HAVE
ABSOLUTELY HEARD OF,
BUT STILL DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY.
BUT IF YOU WANTED TO,
THIS GROUP HAS
THE KNOWLEDGE YOU SEEK.
IN "JUDAS AND THE BLACK
MESSIAH," SEAN BOBBIT FINDS
EXCITEMENT IN RESPONDING
TO WHAT ACTORS DO WHEN
THEY ARE IN A SPACE.
IN "MANK," ERIK
MESSERSCHMIDT LOVES
PREDICTING THE
MOMENT OF AN ACTOR.
IN "NEWS OF THE WORLD,"
DARIUSZ WOLSKI LOVES
THE NUANCES THAT THE
ENVIRONMENT BRINGS TO A SCENE.
IN "NOMADLAND," JOSHUA
JAMES RICHARDS WAS
INSPIRED BY ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO EXIST NATURALLY
WITHIN A RAW LANDSCAPE.
AND FINALLY, IN "THE TRIAL OF
THE CHICAGO 7," PHEDON
PAPAMICHAEL, FINDS A VISUAL
LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH A PULSE.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
ERIK MESSERSCHMIDT,
"MANK."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WOW.
UM, WOW.
I WISH I COULD CUT
THIS INTO FIVE PIECES
’CAUSE IT’S SUCH AN HONOR
TO BE NOMINATED
AMONGST ALL OF YOU.
IT’S AN INCREDIBLE HONOR.
DAVID, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CREATING
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WE COULD DO OUR
BEST WORK
AND I GOT TO GO
HOME AND FEEL LIKE I GAVE
IT MY ALL EVERY NIGHT.
THANK YOU.
CEAN, THANK YOU FOR
THE ENDLESS SUPPORT.
ERIC ROTH, THANK YOU
FOR THE GUIDANCE.
AMANDA, GARY, WHAT A
PRIVILEGE AND A JOY TO
WATCH YOU WORK.
THE ENTIRE CAST,
THANK YOU FOR HITTING
YOUR MARKS.
IT MATTERED.
AND IT’S -- THIS REALLY
BELONGS TO AN EXTRAORDINARY
CREW WHO I COULD NOT
DO ANYTHING WITHOUT.
BRIAN, WILL, ALEX, DAVE,
GARY, DWAYNE, DANNY, JERRY
AND ALL OF YOUR TEAM,
YOU MAKE MY JOB EASY.
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU TO MY
BEAUTIFUL WIFE NAIARA
WHO TOLERATES THIS CRAZY
BUSINESS AND HELPED ME
GET THROUGH THIS MOVIE,
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.